on pourrait penser que la vie d'enfants
de stars est une vie rêvée
piston avantages en tous genres les
clichés sont nombreux autant il n'est
pas toujours facile d'être fils de qui a
déjà connu quand vous l'avez eue arthur
oui c'est cette forme très difficile et
si les célébrités sont souvent discrètes
sur leur vie de famille il leur arrive
parfois de se livrer c'est le cas de
dany boon qui s'est exprimé il ya
quelques jours sur 7 à vous sur les
difficultés que son fils a rencontré par
rapport à sa notoriété lui à changer de
parfum d'école ils suffisent à emmerder
à l'école alain fabien et anthony les
fils d'alain delon se sont eux aussi
souvent exprimé dans les médias sur leur
relation conflictuelle avec leur père
enfant j'ai vraiment envie qu'ils soient
forts faut lui donner de l'amour johanna
balavoine quant à elle a perdu son père
daniel balavoine alors qu'elle n'avait
que cinq mois elle a dû se construire
avec un père connu de tous mais absent
pour elle nous parle un mec que je
connais pas qui est
très base des histoires bien différentes
mais qui montre que la popularité de ses
aînés n'est pas toujours simple à gérer
alors la vie est-elle vraiment facile
quand on est l'enfant d'une star
à louverné d'être avec nous l'air si mal
où elle est affluence très suivie sur
les réseaux sociaux avec notamment huit
cent cinquante mille abonnés sur timo
glock un ouais
évidemment tu es la fille de deux
grandes stars jean pierre pernaut et
nathalie marqué les deux je les embrasse
très fort les aime fort ils le savent et
toi tu hésites pas parler de ton père
franchement autant la naksa chaîne tout
à toi
en fait il est tellement naturelle c'est
une personne qui est tellement naturel
dans la vie de tous les jours enfin
quand on croise on se dit pas que c'est
quelqu'un qui va présenter le jt tous
les jours ça va présenter du coup le
protocole opposants voilà le coeur non
mais après du coup il est filmé dans
toutes les situations parce qu'en soi et
il est un peu dans leur ville et paraît
que moi il est qu'il est comme dont le
voilà il n'est pareil il est naturel
donc bon tu as vécu comment tout on
enfonce le fit d'eux parce que tu es là
tu acquiers tu m'as dit 18 18 ans à 18
ans donc c'est vrai que quand tu es en
temps réel on courait tout s'était passé
par hulu il ya pas d relou qui viennent
te voir bah en fait les gens qui
viennent par intérêt ont laissé un très
très vite
mais j'en ai des dizaines louis par jour
parce que les gens ils veulent des sages
mais fait ces bâtisses et les personnes
qui est critique dans ton dos et à
partir du moment où ils savent que tu es
la fille d'un quick adore mais tel amour
de loisirs ouais ah oui non mais ses
sorties chalet avec le temps il
d'ailleurs déjà eu des moments
difficiles genre ouais je suis pas des
briques on peut dire que j'aime pas que
nos pères j'aime pas ce qu'il fait ou
pas du tout fiable et ça les gens ne
disent pas forcément et après j'ai de la
chance d'avoir un père quand même assez
apprécié kadorama maire pareil
c'est vrai et enfin 6 on coule donc en
vrai nom je suis revenu un moment à
l'école pas obligatoirement des mecs
fouette a souvent des mares la raconte
voilà parce que c'est la fille de jean
pierre pernaut ça va c'est maurice
boutboul effet dés sont jetés
après quoi
les gens disent que je regarde ma les
jeux mais je me prends pas à dire ça
raconte à scana qui peuvent dire que tu
te raconte ça pour rien en fait oui mais
franchement c'est des gens qui me
connaissent pas parce que je suis tout
sauf comme ça donc non mais toi je te
connais tu es tout sauf comme ça toi
sauf comme ça ce très gentil très
généreuse ah bah t'as vu tes parents
paient pourrait pas être autrement c'est
ça et je sais toute sa famille son frère
aussi sanaa - ouais c'est trop chaud il
ya de la jalousie quand même tu as senti
de la jalousie de codage en
bas ça dépend en fait c'est presque
toujours été dans un cadre où les gens
ils ont toujours connu comme ça ce qui
est compliqué ce qu'on va dans les
études supérieures excellera les gens
qui sont pas trop forcément habitués à
ton mode de vie entre guillemets
ingérable mode de vie normaux même
normal mais en comparaison quand je
parle des réseaux sociaux ils sont
nomades mais juste un
bonjour c'est vrai qu'on était quand
même
des balles comme un type d'homme non
mais oui les gens il faut comme ça mais
après je m'en fiche qui sont jaloux tant
pis pour eux ont choisi heureuse dans ma
vie c'est à dire salaire est à l'air
très bien tu vas faire quoi là alors non
à vis un truc d'intérieur gens l'adorent
instant et si les réseaux ça continue
bas mais servir des réseaux pour faire
un style vraiment jamais lâché je te
prendre en architecte d'intérieur je
dirais caméra et on perd d'accord c'est
vrai il aurait des entretiens pour le
caractère
va pas tarder à me
fais gaffe tu regardes tu as ton fils ça
va te dire et si et je te dire si ton
fils qui va prendre
[Rires]
cela dort dîne chez les dames la presse
que je les aimes tu la jad leboeuf et
avec mercy jade la fille du champion du
monde bien sûr 81,18 franck leboeuf que
j'embrasse d'ailleurs franck que j'adore
qui a fait une magnifique reconversion
tant qu'acteur vraiment et c'est un
bosseur il a réussi sa reconversion
c'est un mec je la dois là il le sait tu
es mannequin et influences euse oui
comme moi
jamais toi quand même
toi comment tu as vécu en plus toi n 98
ouais c'était jour un truc de ouf quoi
servent à l'aise insectes jean pierre o
dessine énorme star là franck leboeuf
non mais c'est vrai on avait un jardin
castaldi c'était serré que tout cela
dans cette mine de rien à cette période
là anthony de ses jours voilà on avait
les plus grandes stars de france que
franck leboeuf c'est un truc de fou
comment tu as vécu ça toi c'était dingue
mois après j'étais petit j'avais 7 ans
et henry quand il a remporté la coupe du
monde en 98 et je m'en rendais pas trop
compte enfin je savais que mon père cd
faisait des grandes choses et qu'il
était apprécié et d'un nombre énorme de
personne ne savait pas trop ce qui va et
toi tu crois qu'il joue au foot en bois
de la maison quand et couvrait après la
non
non non je me rendais compte mais je me
rendais pas compte de sa notoriété à
quel point est plaisait aux gens et
c'est vrai que parfois quand on est vers
nous quand on était en extérieur en mon
nom de famille ça m'embêtait d'avoir du
monde une crue maintien ouais ça parce
que je voulais passer du temps avec mon
papa ma famille mais ça a été plutôt toi
tu avais huit ans dont tu dis quand tu
as quand ton père est devenu une légende
c'est vraiment une légende franck
enfin on parlait que de ça un moment ça
me disait toujours tu es d'été la fille
de frank leboeuf la filtrant que parce
qu'aujourd'hui franchement aujourd'hui
tu as réussi à te faire vraiment un nom
un vraiment aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
toi tu existes pas comme je pense qu'il
ya plein de gens d'ailleurs pour oublier
d'ailleurs tu étais là finalement que le
boeuf je te le dis ça m'a mis à mon avis
on doit lui dire tu es de père de jeanne
le peuvent mais elle te dis pas ça par
fouet mais si quelques articles c'est
sûr le père
je te dis jamais moi maintenant tu es le
père de janost oli de sat
[Rires]
bats toi et non mais c'est vrai ce
qu'est ce qu'on en parlait que de ça ce
que c'est c'est pas un peu roulent moins
bon c'est pas relou parce que ça fait
partie de ma vie j'ai toujours grandi
avec donc on s'est fait mais c'est vrai
que parfois j'ai pas envie de raconter
toute l'histoire de ma vie tout le temps
à tout le monde mais ça c'est marrant
quand j'ai des gens que je connais
depuis des années qui font le lien et
qui tenait son club enfin j'avais pas
fait le lien donc c'est canon parce que
du coup je peux discuter avec eux de ça
aussi qui a pris quand on vient me poser
des questions aussi sur ma vie avec mon
papa ça me dérange pas du tout quand
j'étais plus jeune un petit peu plus bas
lorsque on n'en parlait plus parce qu'il
était davantage dans l'actualité du foot
mais aujourd'hui franchement s'écroule
vous voyez tout le temps où il a tout le
temps en effet que tu donnes des
conseils ça complètement fermée
complètement le groupe jeudi d'effacer
une vidéo sur un stade parce que ça
allait pas du tri de l'arf ouais ouais
ça et puis j'ai vu c'est que j'ai vu
cette vidéo
ouais j'ai vu une vidéo j'ai pas vassale
à la prochaine fois je vais l'appeler
aussi son numéro
ces récits quand votre place kudava pire
souvenir genre un truc vraiment qui vous
a marqué vous êtes dit [ __ ] c'est pas
facile tous les jours un pire souvenir
qu'un truc toi j'en ai un mais mon père
était pas avec moi c'est un jour j'étais
au resto et le serveur je suis même plus
pourquoi d'un coup il ya une amie à moi
tu pouvais pas payer et moi je n'avais
pas pris assez d'argent pour payer enfin
c'est comme ça enfin j'espère bref et
est le serveur qui s'est levé qui m'a
sorti au web à sa fille jean pierre
pernaut tu peux bien payé
donc c'est matthieu delormeau le cervin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je reconnais là et vous avez un pire
souvenir ont pas du tout ouais moi
c'était j'avais à peu près dix ans en
fait on avait vécu à londres et j'étais
scolarisé en angleterre dont le système
anglais les anglais sont très
respectueux je sache qu'on a voilà et
mon père venait jouer pour marseille et
donc c'était tout autre chose on est
parti dans le sud et je suis parti dans
une école et j'arrivais en sixième est
là tous les élèves étaient dans la cour
et il appelait chaque classe chaque
élève à vous allez la cmb là et on est
arrivé à mon nom et là tout le monde
s'est tu attendez de voir qui allait
commencer à bouger et là moi j'étais
j'ai grandi dans un environnement où je
me rendais pas compte que j'avais pas eu
ça autant de moi donc ça m'a énormément
choqué et j'ai pas osé bouger et j'ai
commencé à bouger et la tour applaudis
et j'ai pas compris je suis rentré je
voulais pas retourner à l'école c'était
horrible ans ça m'a énormément choqué
mais en même temps ça m'a fait grandir
quoi et ça mais je me suis rendu compte
de beaucoup beaucoup de choses plus à
porter ça c'est choquant en plus c'est
ça c'est juste que c'était flippant
ouais jeunesse je ne connais pas de cuir
de veau niveau de vos parents t'es fier
de ton papa faille c'est trop cool et ma
maman aussi et ma mère avait un exemple
moi c'est ça ouais trop vache ou tais
toi tu étais heureuse quoi vraiment mais
j'ai la chance d avoir en toi tu étais
tu étais tu dois dire aussi que je suis
extrêmement fier de mes deux parents à
ma maman est tu vas trop dans la lumière
mais mathieu ce aussi changé lundi lé
décor à tricher c'est compliqué aussi
d'être la femme de quelqu'un de très
connu comme ça très exposé je sais
regarder matthieu delormeau il a
beaucoup de mal à
chaussure à son pied non mais c'est vrai
elle a chez sarenza et tous ne trouve
rien
alors on a la chance d'avoir également
julien castaldi fils d'un très grand
animal
est immense pour le plus pour moi le
plus grand benjamin castaldi bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes influenceurs également
alors on vous voit vous ça y est vous
avez pris le même chemin que votre père
moi non mais ça voulait fermer les
livres fait en sorte que c'était vrai
nom que sont peut être votre père
devrait pas spécialement non je suis
quand même un peu tête a envie d'être
voilà tu as envie de faire quand même
des petites est quand même dans la
lumière alors alors justement peut pas
trop trop et j'essaye de je me suis
rendu compte tu sais j'ai fait énergie
certains pas plus que fiona ça m'a plus
humainement c'est chaque fois que les
gens font un truc actionnaires ils sont
pas contents non non
non ça m'a plus humainement c'est une
expérience incroyable
ti fiona houle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mad max était une expérience de
dingue j'ai toujours rêvé tue c'est de
montrer un piaggio et de matelas je
préfére j'ai toujours préféré le maillot
mac
et un bref voilà c'est une super
expérience mais ça va ma montrer que
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas ta came
c'est pas si c'est pas là où je suis
bien c'est pas là où je suis julien tap
ouais tu étais petit eckert était
castaldi à l'antenne
eilat et julien quoi voilà beaucoup plus
non mais ça quand tu es en dehors des
plateaux qui je viens quand tu rentres
sur un plateau d castaldi et c'est
exactement ce que tu préfères être
julien que castaldi tout à fait bah je
te comprends
est-ce que toi tu as eu des moments
difficiles où est-ce que ça a été facile
d'être le papa de l'office de bagram le
papa voici les plus matures que lui
c'est pour toi non mais j'y mets cesa et
non mais
difficile quand tu es petit tu as la
critique des enfants de toutes les
façons donc genre coalisant me disais
ouais tu as on s'en fout ton père
ivoirien tout ça
[Rires]
en fait encore une côte et que et que tu
es et que tes enfants en plus sur temps
vous sur le souvent les enfants ils sont
conseillés par leurs parents donc deux
sur des propos qui ne sont pas si ça
donc ils entendent un truc couette avec
le nom mais c'est vrai que tu sur moi je
suis sûr que mes enfants aient des rues
du village avec le condamnons donc en
fait ils te sortent des propos qui
viennent prennent leur bouche donc ils
sont beaucoup plus blessants parce que
je suis était petit tu comprends pas
qu'ils ont été blessés parfois oh oui
j'ai été blessé plusieurs fois en plus
j'avais pas physiquement j'étais pas
j'étais pas au top donc tu vois tu dois
choate un peu le reflet de ton père ceux
qui ne connaissent pas donc donc j'ai
pris j'en ai pris pour mon futur c'est
un ma pomme j'aime bien quand j'étais
petit il
presque obèse on va pas se mentir
c'est toujours sabres avec vous un
[Rires]
juge vient quand ils étaient obèses
vraiment rien on may hamm et donc il a
beaucoup souffert et après c'est vrai
que le lui là le pauvre quand j'ai pas
manquer exploser c'est élise le loft et
moi je pouvais même plus venir chercher
à l'école c'était pas possible ils
venaient ils venaient en chapeau en
cagoule avec le garde du corps
lorsqu'une une exfiltration de l'école
je ne connais pas tu pries je me faisais
enlevé genre ça sérieusement il venait
chez en train décédé et donc non mais
sérieusement je vous rendez pas service
était le leur frange passe et c'était un
truc de les genres et emma ball dont
bien sûr j'ai entendu des trucs qui
tombe laissés sur ton père ah oui le
pire c'est tu sais il ya un moment il
avait fait un article où j'étais pas au
courant ce que j'étais en internat où il
pensait mettre fin à ses fins m mais
mettre fin à sa vie tu vois et du coup
les gens sont venus me voir en disant tu
sais que ton père a projeté de d'en
finir et tout donc quand tu es en
interne a capté dans un attentat c'est
la journée que tu entends ça tu leur dis
mais tenace n'importe quoi elle est
arrêtée bêtise et on a un deux cinq dix
quinze les profs julien tu es sûr que ça
va on a lu la presse je peux voir la
presse et ils m'ont montré le la presse
où mon père me disait disait qu'il était
utile était pas bien et tout alors je
sais pas et je le dis on a on m avait
des invités je lui ai je lui avais dit
il ya un article si si il y avait il ya
aussi il ya eu un fait une presse où tu
disais que tu voulais
j'aurais pleuré au pire oui voilà que tu
pense au pire mais les gens tu sais
comme ils sont quand tu dis je pensais
tu vas donc voilà ça c'était le vraiment
la partie la plus à même vous soyez vue
[Rires]
non mais je me rends pas compte c'est
franchement ça me plaît parce que c'est
vrai que le projet pas propre quand j'ai
des réponses et de conneries et pape du
tout pensé mais d'assurance pour sauver
ces non pas du tout c'est pas du tout
pensé j'imagine la voile à seynod mais
il n'y a pas de souci il ya prescription
et puis on a rattrapé certains idée
quand même à être le fils de benjamin
parce que tu nous l'as dit que ce test
nous a dit que c'est hype a pu mais de
rien je pense que sa taille mais aussi
pour intégrer la télévision ah oui alors
pour attirer la télévision sa nature oui
c'est sûr que j'ai eu un vip pass mais
j'ai fait un casting on était une
dizaine et le salaire n'est pas fatigué
tu es très bon julien jeu le 2 mai voilà
vrai que michèle et vérité moi c'est pas
l objet pareil c'est pareil pour moi
quand un truc armes à m'engager j'étais
un questionnaire j'aimerais bien qu'il
engageait et il m'a pris pour le cinéma
il avait les grands parents notamment
s'élèvent dans le cinéma non pour lui
c'est et voilà c'était c'était utile
mais ça vous aviez du talon aussi
benjamin mais là où la demande est bien
beau pour le piston on en a tous à tous
les niveaux on a toujours fait du coup
de piston qu'on soit dans la voilà
charcutier ce qui est embêtant c'est
quand on reste alors qu'on n'est pas bon
et pour le coup julien était très bon
mais il est pris samedi la télévision
voilà j'ai voulu me prouver que je
pouvais en fait je voulais montrer à mon
père tu sais comment quand et pas bien
dans ta peau que t'as pas vu beaucoup
ton père que tu te rapproches de lui et
plus tard dans une lutte derrière moi
aussi je peux faire donc j'ai fait ça
pendant un an c'était extra j'ai
rencontré des gens formidables
guillaume fiona y est mais c'étaient des
personnes vraiment qui montent qui
montent ils m'ont aidé à apprendre en
fait fi n'est finalement que ce n'était
pas fait pour moi et que et que voilà je
serais beaucoup plus heureux sans
essayer de me caler une vie qui n'est
pas la mienne en fait je pourrais tu
peut pas égaler ce qui ce qui la fait tu
peux pas aidé en voilà je n'en voyais
pas faire de la télé rallye très dur
d'égaler ce que vous avez fait serrer
bas je sais tu t'imagines 16 millions de
téléspectateurs ccc ccc que cinq femmes
vous savez ce qu'il a refusé pour le
coup alors ça a été incroyable 2 x files
a refusé de faire secret' il vous devez
rentrer comme j'avais comme comme secret
mon père et mon père et le père de la
télé-réalité c'est ford a refusé de le
faire pourquoi ont ils m'ont appelé mais
toutes les téléréalités m'ont appelé me
t'imagines et vous et c'est qu'il ya eu
la même chose avec isabelle mal a failli
rentrer mon père et le père de
l'humanité
[Rires]
je les buts on te regrettera dit auriel
sans rigoler
à la et mais aujourd'hui je te sont
alors ouais je sais pas si vous avez
réalisé je le sens ah ouais on dirait
que tu as tu perds ma depuis la règle et
c'est quoi aujourd'hui ttec une meuf t'a
tekton je suis fiancée la semaine
prochaine ce sera toi
quel china cauc et syna
mais sur quoi tu fais oui j'aimerais
bien me marier l'année prochaine tu vas
mourir j'ai emmené un terrain où
l'aviation jeter invités pour le bien
vous n'êtes pas venu mais je peux vous
rajoutez pas m'échauffer jamais au
mariage de saab alors oui je veux bien
[Rires]
non mais ça oui moi je voudrais j'ai un
modèle on va dire que c'est pas
l'exemple parfait pour les les mariages
long termiste mon père mais mais
persiste oui il qu'ils vont très très
loin ou qui durera en fait j'ai vraiment
un modèle un peu idyllique du mariage
j'aimerais avoir une femme pour toute ma
vie je les trouvais foule trop mignon
c'est bon elle lui qu elle adore
extraordinaire et la tamouls je suis par
aman s'appelle comment s'appelle chiara
chara ouais
ouais une allemande
n'en seriez vous la connaissez très bien
bien suivre est clairement assez lé père
spéciaux n'est quoi qu'on en dise est
présenté mon père alors étrangement
c'est aussi alors pas dans le milieu
médias mais c'est aussi une fille de
personnes assez importante dans un autre
secteur c'est que c'est les deux camps
voilà dans un autre secteur donc il y
avait pas s'il n'y avait pas ces quarts
à qui c'est qui à leur sens de famille
c'est très rassurant la file williams
non non non non
elle voilà la famille valachie qui bosse
dans une enseigne d'ameublement très
connus électroménager boum boum
choisissez bien sûr
les idées de génie à quoi les aînés
c'est pas vrai mais si quoi son père
c'est non non non j'aurais bien aimé ta
laurent gerra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais la belle fille donc a pas eu ce
truc de comme quand j'étais sur l'a12 où
les nanas le rennais a à foison sur les
réseaux et avec comme seul intérêt de de
côtoyer un fils de là c'était vraiment
hyper hyper sain quoi écoute moi quand
toi tu présenter un financière à ton
père moi je suis en cours depuis six ans
avec mon copain dans le même temps 18
ans
bonjour oui c'est vrai que ça fait
treize je me suis officiellement et que
j'avais 13 ans ouais ouais et hull après
quand on perd la rencontre et tous les
tons stressé déjà mes parents depuis
longtemps et wen aux maires sont très
très copiés donc c'est très cool ces
lignes d'un membre de ma famille
maintenant c'est cool et toi jeune je
suis marié bref ça mais quand a présenté
justement ton mari un geste très tôt
leurs moyens indevin d'organes c'est
fascinant elles sont aussi proposés
mariga à c'était très très cool dre
marie et laiteries détendu voire hilare
il va pas de pression est très cool
ouais et mon père a toujours été très
cool il s'est jamais mêlé ouais mais
chaffin tu vois ici jamais introduit
trou dans ma vie sentimentale est il à
ce faire les choses et si je fais des
archers hors japon mais à voir en tout
cas faut casser la gueule franck restera
que simplement on a été gérée mais alors
vraiment bravo
bravo à victoire bonnot
[Applaudissements]